Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so surprise Star Wars
video Duracell posted this ad for the holiday
shopping season for some of their toys we
know that Disney works really close with toy
manufacturers when it comes to making gads
so what does this promo say about what's going
on in the film so this is going to be a lot
of speculation mixed with things that we already
know about the film so just careful for potential
spoilers for the film but I remind you that
a lot of this is just speculation so no worries
so what is this little girl wearing the days
really costume wielding Luke Skywalker's lightsaber
from return of the Jedi say about the force
awakens while I think that it answers a really
big question that everyone has had about days
really's character one that she's force sensitive
and to that she has something to do with the
Skywalker family is been a lot of people recently
that have been wondering about Luke Skywalker's
relation to Kylo Ren's Luke Skywalker going
to be the villain in these next couple of
films all say flat out hell no to that there's
already been pictures that have leaked of
Luke Skywalker's costume from the movie I'm
not can oppose them here just because they
are super spoil re-but I think the Kylo Ren
and Daisy Ridley share a very special familial
connection to the Skywalker's but it is to
Leia and Han, not to Luke remember there is
another Skywalker who is force sensitive.
it's just that when they posted the first
promo and then they aired the trailer in Rome
was like all I wanted Daisy Ridley to be a
Jedi just like John Boyega but just because
she's not holding a light saber in the promos
doesn't mean that she's not going to become
a Jedi I think I said it in my trailer video
but I don't think that Kathleen Kennedy would
try to introduce more powerful females to
the Star Wars universe and not let any of
them become Jedi but if you want to be super
literal about this commercial you could speculate
that Daisy Ridley will use Luke Skywalker's
lightsaber at some point in the film even
though I think that we would rather see her
wield a dual bladed lightsaber because she
has that Tuscan raider looking staff there
but who knows this is just the first film
in a new trilogy so I don't think were going
to be staying crazy Jedi stuff till the second
film when it comes to new Jedi Darkside characters
be the first film is mostly going to be focusing
on Jon league's character wielding Anakin
Skywalker's light saber in Kylo Ren here with
his own self built light saber but just get
height and I'm not expecting any like big
big Star Wars trailer's to drop between now
and the movie coming out but I do think will
be more short promos and I'll be more toy
stuff like this that will tell us things about
the films in between all that stuff we will
learn a lot more about the film and just reminder
if there's any confusion about big bad's in
the new film and the circuses character is
playing supreme leader's note the supreme
leader of the first-order he is technically
going to be like the new Emperor figure who
also really want to show up to the second
film I think the character that I most hype
about though is Captain Phasma. Gwendolyn
Christie is just so amazing especially game
of thrones speaking of which there is new
game of thrones video coming tonight that
I'm working on so be sure to subscribe to
get that and if there's any other Star Wars
bonus videos you guys want me to do in the
next week or so just let me know in the comments
there are bunch of videogames coming in November,
especially battlefront, so I might do stuff
for that on my game channel once I get a little
bit settled in my new apartment so while you
guys wait for that stuff to post you can click
here to enter the Star Wars infinite trailer
loop you can make the constant like oh my
God it's so beautiful face and then you can
click here for last night's episode of The
Walking Dead, deep dive into the craziest
character on the show. Thank You so much for
watching, everybody let's High Five and I'll
see you tonight!